الحقيقه هذا طبعا موضوع كبير جدا وكثير من
الباحثين والمؤرخين والفلاسفه حاولوا
مناقشه هذا الامر لكن هو ممكن نقول انا من
وجهه نظري الشخصيه نوجد نظري الخاصه يعني
هو انه اذا اردنا ان نستلهم وناخذ العبر
من التاريخ وان نتحول التاريخ الى ماده
رحبه وواسعه وخلاقه وجميله ومدق قد تكون
للتسليه للابداع الى غير ذلك هو اولا يجب
ان نتوقف عن اصدار الاحكام يجب ان نبتعد
عن محاوله القفز لاصدار الحكم والاستعجال
على اخذ مواقف مسبقه تجاه اي شيء دعونا
نقرا التاريخ باعتباره صفحه من الماضي
صفحه ذهبت
نحن لسنا مسؤولين عما حدث وليس من وظيفتنا
ان نجعله لا جميلا ولا شريرا ولا سيئا ليس
لنا دخل فيها هو علينا ان نقرا هذا
التاريخ الهدف الاساسي اولا هو الفهم
الفهم من اجل فهم ان نفهم ما الذي حدث
وكيف حدث وكيف جرى وان التاريخ والمجتمعات
السابقه هي مثلها مثل المجتمعات بشريه
يحدث فيها الخير والشر والجميل ونقرا بهذا
التنوع الكبير ونستلهم منه هذه العبر بعد
ذلك حينما نفهم ونصل للفهم ممكن ان نتناقش
ونتداول هذا الامر اما ان يتحول التاريخ
الى حلبه للصراع فان لن نستفيد ولن نفهم
حقيقه ما جرى في المال